bene tutti ragazzi e per questo nuovi
dire sono parecchie risate di sul rast
nel server ore con tutti youtube
vediamo che diavolo esce fuori oggi
perché io e gabi diciamo che
assomigliano proprio i banditi veri e
propri del serve perché stiamo facendo
quindi mettetevi comodi e godetevi la
episodio ragazzi giorno nessuno al vero
mia moglie tutto favi dai 100 ai
pavimenti lucchetto creato un rifiuto
la signora carla non lo faccia stare
perché se hanno pagato lo sta trattando
con la boe pazzesco 5 secondi gli
chiediamo fuori
vai vai ci voglio credere insomma c'è un
lucchetto in mano come si mette
mettilo come dopo si può non si può
perché dice building blocks non solo
l'edizione apre o potrò di leo rubato la
tuta c'erano anche loro a tutta la band
ha le mele andiamocene andiamocene
andiamocene abbiamo già un sacco di roba
abbiamo rubato tutto va via via via vive
renouveau anni a cavallo che tu hai
preso tutto ok arrivo anche il cavallo
via via via via via via diana meno aiuto
ma ora se lo fanno che si sono bama metà
del nabe tifiamo ma metti un lunga
ghiera pò ma chi era ma non lo sono
visto uscire ma sai che l'ho visto
uscire anche l'ho visto uscire sì sì ma
non pensavo che la dava pirlo
dov'è il mio cavallo aiuto ecco le quali
arrivo abbiamo la base si subito ho
rivisto lui non lo so non ho certo
ragazzi lo meritano
26 dic prendi il mio cavallo ti ricordi
una viola braschi ce l'ho ce l'ho io son
loro
torniamo in base ad essi va anni o verso
la base per ci ritrovavamo ma mia mamma
mia che giocata raga però anche loro a
tenere la porta aperta
no vabbè ma dai ragazzi la prima cosa è
che vuoi essere derubata certo
abbiamo fatto dei geni per ora adesso
mettiamo tutta da guardare la nostra
volta guardarla loro mi sento c'è un
però
eccoti ma non mi fermo se questo aspetto
c'è stesso gestore sospetti ma dove a
causa come te aspetto sereno signore non
ho niente loro sono una mazza chiamata
amore una torta
non ho niente da solo una torta per lei
allora guardi vi faccio vedere un attimo
il mio cavallo sono consola solo arrivo
qua questo il mio cavallo sopra il mio
cavallo c'è della roba guarda adesso ve
la do list o perché l'hanno ma mi ha
seguito e dove c'è lui e nat generoso
aspetta l'aspetta che ho fatto un giro
strano non dovrebbero avermi seguito a
meno che non ci hanno un binocolo che lo
stato ok sono poi in base aspettate
momento assolutamente
entra in base a chiudermi come non se
mamma mia quanto cavalli che a chi è qua
qua identificate vi identificate
no non sorridono ma guardate che noi
sappiamo prego ai ragazzi tre gole vero
bene guardate voi in cui schermistiche
cavalli armati questi armati chi è che
sta tentando di spiegare la rendano di
picconate ragazzi fermi ragazzi io io io
me ne vado certo non si può andare
più stimolanti a queste uscite
guardate che noi abbiamo già abbiamo in
giro una di quelle rocchetta te che non
hai idea lo spaventato spaventando
l'acquisto certo pensare se tiravo fuori
io anche il mitra maledizione come si
kakà questa cosa dobbiamo tirar fuori
proprio l'arrivo del viola armi potenti
ecco vedo cosa fai
ok che toglie risorse dobbiamo fare
secondo me è una cesta nascosta perché
qua dobbiamo farlo sotto sotto terra si
fa ciao ciao muovermi a seconda che ci
facevano fuori tantissimo capitoli ma
secondo me sono ancora qua guarda che
attraverso il muro ma infatti non è a
metà examined infatti dobbiamo adesso
assolutamente dobbiamo fare o daylight
di sleeping dogs però che questo hanno
capito ciò che sta rotolando a wroclaw o
cavolo non ce l'abbiamo comunque allora
aspetta a parte questo io vorrei fare
veramente facciamo così comunque
facciamo così io vado fuori solo nel
caso su 6 mila nomi tipo data tanto vado
solo con
se le lance si è solo quella bisogno
dobbiamo assolutamente fare una certa
delle ceste nascoste perché più che
altro dovremo rafforzare le porte e
questi due memori di lei non lo faccio
io subito da dentro guarda perché se lo
metti in mezzo a quei materiali che
abbiamo rubato scusami cioè mammamia
pieno dirò no no non ho mai fatti
abbiamo farle provate meno male che
guarda se abbiamo però la pistola era va
morti è veramente io ho cominciato fare
mas al 20 siamo franchi non si preoccupi
accusando
salve amici abbiamo portato un regalo un
regalo per voi
eccolo qua e la torre a lei a lei ma lei
bella torta è il blu
avete notato che nelle nostre sparito
qualcosa cosa è sparito
non ho chiedo se questa sparito qualcosa
ultimamente aspettatemi mista a parte il
mio capo sta arrivando il mio capo poi
può parlare con lui giorno le abbiamo
portato di non perdervi la torta ha
quindi tu vuoi fare un'alleanza con noi
che abbiamo sia gente che arriva quasi
in fiore c'è qualcuno salve buongiorno
anche per caso sparita delle robe
dall'eccesso controllo al volo vicini al
gol signore ai e non posso più uscire
volevo imparare non lo so niente sono
solo queste due cose qua in realtà
sembrerebbe che non ci sia niente di
manca né lo so qui manca qualcosa
quella no siete stati voi per caso no
abbiamo visto la mia visto che è stato
vista abbiamo visto che è stata
praticamente che noi possiamo dire
possiamo dire delle cose in cambio delle
altre informazioni noi diamo
informazioni in cambio di informazioni
e chi può garantire che invece non siete
voi decidete voi
siamo una cosa esatto loro mi sembrano
abbastanza salvi favi non parla e questa
cosa mi fa abbastanza povero basta far
mistero ma ero con push to talk tutto il
tempo scusate io mi stavo parlando a
casa salve buongiorno a tutti allora noi
siamo venuti qua per noi abbiamo visto
delle persone però noi non diciamo
informazione in cambio di niente è un po
di cose almeno e dell'informazione
avevo capito però è perché tu 22 robe
siamo inutili e vabbè e nella famiglia
non sappiamo già che è stato step perché
ce l'ha già detto gabbi ma noi non siamo
cattivi e siccome ce l'ha detto prima
noi potrà potremmo dire no andatevene
via tanto ce l'avete già attivi da un
pochettino di roba qualche pezzo dosso
nome pensi possa penso che possano
bastare perché noi siamo sempre in grado
di guardiamo tutto è qui ma mela grazie
fitto anche qualche amico grazie ragazzi
avrai faccia la grazia emil molto
gentile sapete chi sono in quella semi
alleanza giusto e mi alleanza stretta se
avete bisogno di qualcosa di d'ora in
poi se ci chiamate al telefono e noi
diciamo le informazioni un call center
comunque una domanda vuoi ed eros ipad
dove abitiamo noi ma voi dove state
allora noi in questo momento siamo in
guerra e quindi
praticamente la nostra casa si trova non
è non visto dare un riferimento preziosi
non ci sono i me 10 nel 10 ok siamo
vicino n 10 quindi non so se lo vedi
come perché n 10 benissimo va bene
adesso dovete andarvene se no vi
ammazziamo
va bene ma di dio abbiamo il discorso
abbiamo il disturbo è salve grazie in
noi gli abbiamo rubato la roba ci siamo
fatti dare altra roba si è ma nel mentre
che loro ci dava un altra roba io le ho
rubato altra roba
ok che non era più niente ovviamente
parlavo ricevono ma scusate lara lancio
distin questa accesso a se manca ora ne
prende quattro delle rocce diventare
credi bravissimo ceneremo incattiviti
contro step esa che abbiamo fatto tutto
giusto ai capelli che non fanno niente
sono mettere zizzania tra la gente
my boy savona abbiamo rubato tutto aiuto
quali occhialini robero benetton
abbiamo provato tutto tre volte alle
stesse persone credo che che non
facendoli crede che sia stato stesso
comunque volevo dire che li proseguito
di faremo ancora di peggio perché per
ora siamo stati cattivi ma pacifici però
episodi mamma costigliola piovo ragazzi
nessuno mai si chiede al canale civili
al posto episodio e xavi
[Musica]